yeah welcome to tucker carlson tonight
happy thursday nobody seems to remember
this but it was just a few months ago
that joe biden gave the so-called intel
community a vital new mission
they had he said until the end of august
to find out where the coronavirus came
from did it emerge from a pangolin in a
wet market
or did the chinese military create the
virus in a bio-weapons lab in wuhan
joe biden assured us he was going to get
to the bottom of that he had the
canniest sleuths in the world working on
that mystery they'll figure it out he
said you can trust them
so here we are at the end of august
and what's the answer where did covid
come from
so far no one has told us and we're
starting to suspect that nobody ever
will it's like the media are planning to
push that issue vladimir putin's not
from china they don't care the
coronavirus investigation what
coronavirus investigation
like joe biden himself they have no
memory of anything that happened three
months ago and come to think of it maybe
that was the whole point of the exercise
you announce a fake inquiry into
something you have absolutely no
interest in learning more about and then
you bet on the fact that everyone will
forget that inquiry exists
it's pretty tricky
maybe that's the real purpose of the
intel agencies actually not to gather
intelligence but to provide political
cover to the politicians who control
them oh that's a good question wolfe all
of the cia look into it and get back to
you
right just stay on the line this call
may be monitored for quality assurance
it sounds cynical we know
but it is striking when you think about
it just how often politicians invoke the
intel community when they're lying to
you here was joe biden just last month
your own intelligence community has
assessed that the afghan government will
likely collapse that's not true
is it can you please clarify what they
have told you about whether that will
happen or not that is not true
they did not they didn't did not reach
that conclusion
so the intel agencies never said the
taliban would sweep into kabul that's
what joe biden claimed
do you believe him you probably don't
the intel world may be partisan and
deceitful it certainly is but we're
betting they're not completely stupid
obviously they knew the afghan
government could collapse
they must have told joe biden or at
least the people around joe biden can we
prove that they told him no we can't
prove it and that's the beauty of using
the intel agencies for cover you get to
make any claim you want to make and no
one can prove you're lying because the
truth is highly classified
maybe you're starting to understand why
no one ever defunds the cia they're too
useful
so that was from july the clip that we
just played at the time biden told us
the intel community quote did not reach
the conclusion that the afghan
government would fall to the taliban
well now it's august and the afghan
government has indeed fallen to the
taliban that's not our assessment as
they say in washington it actually
happened as you know
the afghan troops threw down their
rifles the president ran away there's a
black taliban flag hanging over the
capitol
so how did this all happen and more to
the point how did our extravagantly
funded intelligence agencies not know it
was going to happen well actually they
did know sort of that's joe biden's new
position he explained it yesterday on
abc news watch
back in july you said a taliban takeover
was highly unlikely
was the intelligence wrong or did you
downplay it there was no consensus you
go back and look at the intelligence
reports they said that it was like more
likely to be sometime by the end of the
year you following this
in the space of a single month the
official line went from our intelligence
agencies think everything is fine in
afghanistan two there was no consensus
in the intelligence agencies that
everything was not fine or something
like that it's not exactly clear what
joe biden was saying there all we can be
totally certain of is that we will never
get to see the documents he was
referring to so really
anything could be true assuming truth
still exists
pretty smart
mark milly the chairman of the george
chiefs of staff is not as clever a
smarter man might have couched his lies
for plausible deniability down the road
but unfortunately mark milley is not
that man so here's what he claimed this
week in public
there was nothing
that i or anyone else saw
that indicated a collapse
of this army and this government in 11
days
um that was totally unequivocal
according to mark milley there was zero
intelligence quote nothing that i or
anyone else saw suggesting a coming
collapse in afghanistan so he literally
had no idea what was coming because
nobody told him the people paid to keep
track were not keeping track the intel
agencies failed completely
and given their budgets in power that is
shocking if you think about it for a
minute clearly someone should be fired
if not court-martialed
but no says joe biden that's not true
in fact says joe biden looking straight
into the face of his old friend now the
anchor at abc
no one in the entire u.s government and
certainly not in the white house could
have done anything different or better
as we withdrew from afghanistan the bad
parts you saw in television were
inevitable
no mistakes of any kind by anyone
connected in any way to joe biden
occurred no one can be blamed for
anything no one should feel guilty
everyone's sleeping just fine thank you
very much
watch
you don't think this could have been
handled besides it could have been
handled
better in any way no mistakes
no i i don't think it could have been
handled in a way that there
we're going to go back in hindsight and
look but the idea that somehow there's a
way to have gotten out without chaos
ensuing i don't know how that happens i
don't know how that happened so for you
that was always priced into the decision
yes
really mr president you couldn't handle
this better in any way not even a tiny
adjustment
no says joe biden meanwhile desperate
people tumble from airplanes thousands
of feet in the air many thousands of
americans remain trapped tonight in a
country now controlled by the taliban
but no problem says the president
how do you assess a statement like that
well our friend piers morgan described
it as quote breathtakingly arrogant and
disturbingly delusional and that sounds
about right if possibly a little
understated
watching it you wonder does joe biden
understand what this moment means to the
country he leads
we had to leave afghanistan he was right
about that it was always going to be
ugly that is true
but this ugly
this humiliating this destructive to
america's authority in the world that's
damaging to our future
no
none of that was foregone none of that
was necessary all of that was a choice
that joe biden and his advisors made
intentionally over months they priced it
in as he just told us they knew it was
going to happen but they did it anyway
what does that say about them
what does it tell you that they left
thousands of american citizens behind
when they fled and then seemed and seem
markedly unconcerned about what might
happen to those american citizens in
afghanistan under the taliban
well it tells you an awful lot
the united
to restate
exists to serve its own citizens the u.s
government exists to serve its own
citizens period the u.s government has
no other purpose the moment the u.s
government stops serving u.s citizens is
the moment the u.s government becomes
illegitimate
that is true that has always been true
since the day the country was founded
and it is obvious to most people who
live here
does joe biden understand it
sincerely it's possible that he doesn't
toward the end of his interview with abc
there was a telling exchange that
exchange was never broadcast on camera
now television networks edit interviews
very often for time
but abc news appears to have chosen to
edit out portions that made joe biden
look how to put it
not presidential incoherent confused
we think it's worth knowing what
happened
especially in a moment of national
crisis so we're going to read from the
transcript that we were provided and
here it is
george stephanopoulos i think of a lot
of americans even a lot of veterans who
served in afghanistan agree with you on
the big strategic picture they believe
we had to get out
but i wonder how you respond to an army
special forces officer javier mckay
he did seven tours he was shot twice he
agrees with you he says we have to cut
our losses in afghanistan but he adds i
just wish we could have left with honor
here's joe biden's response
look
that's like asking my deceased son beau
who spent six months in kosovo in a year
in iraq as a navy captain and then major
i mean as an army major
and you know i'm sure he had regrets
coming out of afghanistan i mean out of
iraq
he had regrets to what's how it's going
but the idea what's the alternative
end quote
now we're waiting for that tape but
that's the transcript
now the president's son was in the navy
not the army
he was in the army not the navy
it's not clear from that we believe he
was in the army and not the navy he did
not serve in afghanistan he served in
kosovo and iraq
joe biden can't seem to remember those
details
we're not attacking him we're not
telling you this with glee we're telling
you because it's true this is the man
leading our country
now the scary thing about what's
happening in afghanistan is not that
afghanistan is collapsing afghanistan
has always been in various states of
collapse by our standards for a thousand
years
the scary thing about afghanistan is
that it reveals american weakness and
weakness of bets aggression
power vacuums are always filled
the problem with what we just read you
is that it reveals weakness at the very
center of the u.s government weakness
that possibly can't be fixed
that's the real problem
over time it's the real threat
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else